I think I'm more optimistic than I would
have been 10 or 20 years ago I'm more
optimistic because I see more lives
being made better more quickly than at
any time in the history of the planet
I'm more optimistic because I see the
tremendous potential of the United
States I see the resilience of a global
market economy that has proven more
resilient to all kinds of shocks from
Russia's default Mexico's near near near
default that's proven itself more
resilient than then many would have
supposed I see here at Harvard the
tremendous commitment to transcend
selfishness on the part of an
extraordinarily able group of young p of
young people who we assemble all of that
together probably makes me have more
optimism though a worried optimism that
I would have had 10 or 20 years ago